earlier this month we reported on the
cluster of kids here in southern Nevada
with rare and serious brain abscesses
Specialists with the CDC are
investigating this cluster and tonight
an update on what factors may have
contributed to this Spike and an
increase in illnesses in general among
kids since the pandemic
I haven't had as many cases so far in
2023 but I do know that other colleagues
across the country are still seeing
cases Dr Taryn Bragg is a pediatric
neurosurgeon for Intermountain Primary
Children's Hospital out of Utah and
Sunrise Children's Hospital here in Las
Vegas I'm the only full-time board
certified pediatric neurosurgeon in the
entire state after March of 2022 Dr
Bragg noticed an alarming Trend in
notified snhd she was treating more kids
for brain abscesses pus-filled pockets
of infection that spread into the brain
in my practice I have normally would see
one to two patients a year it's very
unusual to see more than that and 18 was
quite extraordinary eight-year-old
Carter Hayes is one of those 18
survivors I was like in pain most of the
time and I couldn't move so it was like
hard for me to like get up and do stuff
after numerous brain surgeries he is
recovering Dr Bragg says the mature
authority of the 18 cases were among
middle school-aged boys kids with no
underlying medical conditions the
experts looked at a number of factors
including common activities exposure
travel a history of covid-19 infection
but they didn't find anything that
linked the cases Dr Bragg says there are
several theories as to why doctors may
be seeing an increase in not only brain
infections but infections in general
among kids since the pandemic one of
those theories is is something called
immunity debt or perhaps because we were
quarantined and masking that we
developed a relative sense of maybe
immunosuppression or maybe that we just
hadn't been exposed to those organisms
and therefore they might be more
aggressive at the time that we then
encountered them the other theory has to
do with the fact that coveted numbers
have declined the other common pediatric
viruses that we would see or illnesses
that we would see are starting to
increase
and therefore this is just a spike
related to the increase in those numbers
that perhaps are higher because they're
no longer competing with covid as the
primary source of infection so I think
they're both valid explanations that
could account for what we were seeing in
these children
Dr Bragg's hopeful the CDC can look into
this cluster further she wants to make
sure there isn't anything that can be
changed in terms of risk factors that
would help decrease or mitigate the
chance of kids developing brain
infections for more on this story and
the particular symptoms Dr Bragg wants
parents to be aware of go to our website
8newsnow.com